[Music]
and it booty like groceries news I did
spread it oh you did here and then if I
let go then it goes back in its I opened
it wine submitted by Gina marry me Oh
another proposal well just gonna marry a
stranger like that oh man I see the bank
account and then that's good responsible
a pastor has come under fire for saying
you wanted to quote eat Nicki Minaj's
booty quote on Instagram Wow but he's
just quoting lyrics though I want to eat
up which has nothing to do with eating
booty
he said I'll love to eat your booty at
Nicki Minaj with a whole bunch of emojis
I feel like and what's wrong with that
pastor pastors don't eat booty not in
public I'm not a mother but you verbally
say that about that priests that decide
to be celibate but pastors can sorry
pastor Lee I'm sick I'm assuming this is
like old people internet like they don't
realize that what they comment shows up
on the newsfeed so stupid yeah so Nicki
Minaj posted this photo she looks good
by the way she has a big ass it's just
not real but she looks like a [ __ ]
horse she does actually
centaurs I'm telling you man everyone
looks like a centaur now [ __ ] man all
he's what shot they look like centaurs
or they look like the even 39 the
stepsisters and the mom from Cinderella
to let get centaur
I don't like booties that big I don't
think I could even hit her [ __ ] cuz my
dick isn't bigger huh that shit's big yo
he gets him away right yeah but maybe if
she bends over not standing up like that
too small for that big-ass horse to not
work they just say black dick is huge I
don't know it is I've seen it he says if
she's bending over though then it's easy
if she's standing up like that there's
too much cheek hmm to get inside
ah I'd be [ __ ] all bonds
[ __ ] the air hips are getting in the
waves spread wider let me get in there
at least you'll get off she won't feel
[ __ ]
maybe I wonder but shots feel like like
lip injection because I got lip
injections once a while back it's faded
now but you can feel it in there
oh you're like gel or like yeah oh you
can feel the round gels in there there's
a goal way
bump it yeah it goes away like if you
don't keep it up it just dissolves so
it's gone now like I got really really
small my new injections but if your butt
feels like that that sucks why it's
different too because there's that you
have your gluttonous Maximus you know
you have like your muscles lose me don't
cuss at me but like imagine putting a
marble like just holding a marble
between your lips oh my god rubbing it
together well you can feel sure you grab
the butt and then you feel like butt fat
the muscle and also whatever the
injection is so this pastor his church
found no there you Pastor Jones know so
what happened was someone posted this
screenshot on Twitter and said pastor
wants to eat Nicki Minaj his booty and
so it's pasture what'd it say so it's
this green chattering man and pastor
[ __ ] you a bastard he doesn't oh yeah
I remember he's a soldier too though
that was the soldier talking not the
pastor yeah well you might have been
confessing to God I would eat one of
your creatures booties like you can
confess the cobbler he doesn't have to
type it out all people on the Internet
pervert ones or just just funny it's not
a good idea it's just funny because his
[ __ ] picture now I can see why it
stood out yeah in his [ __ ] uniform
that stupid idiot ID no wonder yeah like
if I was scrolling through comments I'm
gonna look at the picture Mike what the
[ __ ] yeah of course
okay that makes sense not why it like
stuck out to this dude his username is
Dewberry underscore 2017 right so the
pastor he's saying that someone created
this Instagram page he has another one
that's just called Dewberry Instagram
and it's private so he's saying that
that's his actual page but that this one
someone created and their petition so
you have such a [ __ ] fanatic yeah
on your hand here that he's in a copy
and reupload like he's fading when our
fans don't do that
yeah at the point of him posting this he
had a hundred and six posts and all of
them were just like his selfies are
pictures of him and his family and the
oldest post was from January 2016
so it's like okay for an entire year the
fans hardcore do I have a piece every
year yeah and so he posted that on
Facebook and then people on Facebook for
it they even didn't believe him they
said how is this fake you've used this
page and then he says I did not create
that page so he's just trying to play it
off like Facebook yeah cuz he posts it I
can't I don't have the post on it from
PayPal your God's gone upon it you know
what's funny is that he's trying to like
cover his tracks but he's also not very
tech savvy mm-hmm so people can kind of
call out his lie that's like the people
who messaged me [ __ ] and I expose him
they're like I was hacked but they type
the same exact way that the other person
goes would you [ __ ] expose them to
their wives and [ __ ] and their family
that's the best thing in the world for
that and it got shut down there's
literally other instagrams that are
dedicated to just dude sending dick pics
and mine gets shut down
someone got my hurt no no yours got shut
down because you called people out I
blocked out all names
that's 100 right use the grass do this
went viral that particular Instagram
page started posting some really weird
[ __ ] so this is what his page looks like
now and he's just posting photos of
girls saying how hot they are he's
trying to pretend that he is getting
hacked
yeah like so all right so now like all
these other posts and then there's also
Odin oh yeah a whole bunch of Instagram
pages that are him but instead of
Dewberry 2017 it's like 2018 2019 20
whatever it is making more gains so
popular
really committed to this life what if he
really got in a fight with someone and
he is being targeted happening for a
year like I'm petty as [ __ ] but I'm not
gonna commit a whole year to that man
there are some petty people loaded like
his degree in the like in the middle of
all this so here are some of the posts
that he was saying like someone's trying
to be me report this fake page and then
hands up posting like oh here's my
certificate from Military College yeah I
don't even think there's anything bad
about saying you wanted to eat make you
mine I was just asked but then all the
cover up in lies I didn't ask the part
where I'm like you're a shady
[ __ ] if you're a good pastor you
would have [ __ ] went to church on
Sunday and said yes I love to [ __ ]
women God made me this way and I accept
it there's nothing in the Bible that
says thou shalt not [ __ ]
thou shalt not pasta though salad there
is you can I think you're not supposed
to have anal sex cuz that's called
sodomy really yeah but I think you can
eat ass so he should what he should say
is you know what I was just being honest
and today today's sermon is about
honesty I want all you men and women out
there to to be completely honest I would
not listen to him any more it'd be like
you're just as bad as me why the [ __ ] am
i listening to you because he actually
doesn't fall asleep in reads the Bible
okay no then I'll make him my friend not
my not my mentor I'm try to be better
what the [ __ ] just talk to him
afterwards you go counterclockwise or
clockwise
I prefer both skinny tongue are wide
time it's funny how people put pastors
on a pedestal cuz my uncle he's a
retired pastor and I was like I'll
respect y'all ass for you so stupid
cuz he's actually a really good
charismatic speaker like he's really fun
to be around he's funny he he he makes
you feel good you know so I think people
like that about him in the entertainment
but no one's that special like if you
spend 24 hours with someone like day to
day then you start seeing their flaws
you start seeing
certain things about them and you're
like actually you ain't the greatest
person on earth yeah you know it's
interesting I had this friend her dad
was a pastor and I didn't see them that
often growing up but as an adult he
ended up befriending me on Facebook and
he wanted to do it with you know he just
made me feel weird like the messages
you're sending me I can't remember
exactly what he was it horny no like it
wasn't it was like borderline borderline
like this this isn't appropriate but it
wasn't too much where I was like what
the [ __ ] was he testing the waters I
think he was wanna get baptized in his
bikini no I wasn't that far it was kind
of like oh you grow up to be like so
beautiful and it sounds innocent but
then it just made me feel uncomfortable
or like like that where I was like uh
unfriend
that's not a really low yeah so I was
just like unfriend I feel uncomfortable
and then I can't I couldn't tell my
friend either like you're dead sent me
word messages cuz and that would be even
more awkward so just like I'll just
remove myself from this family look I
love it and family because well I used
to work in a bar in Orange County when I
was like early 20s and these are like
Vietnamese bars I'm fully clothed
whatever always have chicks in bikinis
this one I was [ __ ] fully clothed
coffee shop no matter what
fried chicken stuff Airlines there's
just no matter what girls are they just
follow piece up for my place we were in
full clothes
and there's this guy that was hitting on
me the whole time he was older I was
like like I don't have to sit down and
talk to you that's a [ __ ] douche [ __ ]
the next day my uncle comes in all day
and go what's up and then say next thing
was that same guy just like that's my
niece and I was like oh yeah I loved it
that's pretty funny hope you guys
enjoyed that video but if you didn't
guess what you can directly contribute
to the articles that we discussed just
cruise on over to the description box
below click on that link to submit your
article also for the next video rat up
hey
[Music]